hey hey you really happy yeah I am Gazoo
good news I got some great news
oh brother I love you I could not have
stayed in here a second long I just got
my house appraised and it's worth like
thirty thousand dollars more than I paid
for it I what it was appraised for like
thirty thousand dollars more than I paid
so I'm gonna be I'm gonna make a lot of
money that's not good news
sorry what what part of me flipping my
house for $30,000 isn't good news I mean
the part that has nothing to do with me
that part I thought you meant you had
good news for me I do I do have some
good news for you great I met a woman
that that is not good news for me she is
so hot have you seen Modern Family no
you've never seen Modern Family there's
a woman on there she's latina smoking
hot maybe Persian I met a woman hotter
than that and she's into me
or should I say I'm into her when you
say you get it I'm into her physically
we did it this isn't good news yet is
now you can be happy for me and my nice
lamp piece look I want good news
about me and about my case oh I see
I guess good news about me killing it in
the real estate market in the ass market
isn't something to celebrate with your
client my bad oh just keep it about me
please okay okay I actually do have some
good news about your case
yeah I bought a boat and see you see
that's the exact opposite of it being
news about me no no it's about you I
named the boat after you you named your
boat mad no that is a stupid name for a
boat I named it guilty but Gil with two
L's like a fish's gills yeah it's good
to have a nautical pun right it's about
you because I sometimes sit on the deck
of the SS guilty and work on your case
in fact just last night there was a gust
from the northeasterly region
these are seaman terms and a good
portion of your file fell into the ocean
or as we call it the drink so you know
the parts that aren't at the bottom of
the sea are probably a seagull master
something papier-mache for a crab which
leads me to the purpose of my visit
Matthew why are you in prison is it
arson got that arson face